The Joe Rogan Experience Robert can you
explain some of the um
what you ended up finding out was hidden
from you
what was the exculpatory evidence
oh
they would they would have held that uh
first of all first of all uh
maybe I can explain the crimes right
that was a spirit of crime that happened
in the French Quarters in New Orleans
it was
to I think three armed robberies uh a
rape and a kidnapping
and a murder was tied to that so he they
it took all these crimes and said it was
a part of a spree
all right they had a um a car that was
involved
uh in a crime and
they eventually
over the period well go to a couple of
weeks after the crime happened maybe
um they found out who the car
that was involved and
during the time when they was during the
investigation my name came up as a as
anonymous tip came in right so what they
what they did was they eventually
arrested me
and connected me to the car
that was actually used in in all these
breeds of crime including the the murder
the robbery the kidnappings and the rape
uh
uh and
years later uh it eventually found out
that
another guy got arrested for the murder
uh
and was connected
hit in his possession he had possessed
it
jury and articles of evidence from each
crime spree
and from each of the victims yeah he had
jewelry from the woman that was robbed
he had clothing from one of the other
women I think the woman that was raped
right
um and they never turned this over to
him right
and so yeah they would they would have
held that
um from me that was that that how did
they connect you with the car
that's that's what I'm about to explain
they connected me the car how they
connected me with the car uh
uh the the prosecutor didn't was that
like when they arrested this guy they
got him to
say that
me and him was friends
and he he allowed me to use the car
right
at times uh the commit the crime but all
I ever just suggested uh
uh differently
and
so at trial what they did was they
charged
he got convicted of the actual murder
right
he got convicted of murder and it
separated him from the other crimes and
it charged me with the other crimes
right
but I'm unbeknownst to me
uh on the dead trial that I was uh
for the rape kidnapping in their own
robberies
that
uh
he told the prosecutor that I had
nothing to do with none of the crimes
that he I never used a car none of that
right
but when I went to trial a prosecutor
said something totally opposite they
prosecute me on the theory that means
God was best friends he allowed me to
use did you know him I didn't know him
at all and I was seeing them a day in my
life
and the short answer to your question
Joe about what they had connecting him
to the car a driver's license you would
think a driver's license a registration
Insurance someone that had seen them in
the car the answer is they had
absolutely nothing they had a word they
had the word of a guy that had been
accused and tied to these murders who
was looking to put it on someone else
how did he put it on you though
he found out that there was a tip well
implicating him right right
absolutely and so he tried to be a
snitch to get the heat off of him and
put it on you absolutely
and they let that happen yep even though
they knew right it goes deep with this
than that uh so after I get convicted
uh
uh I'm still charged with the with the
murder of the British tourists right
still I'm still actually charged with it
even though I haven't been going back
and forth to court with it at this time
after I get convicted and I know I was
going to get a life sentence for the
rape uh the kidnapping the three armed
robbers
uh
so the district attorney
uh
made an offer to my defense attorney
um and eventually brought it to me on
the day of my sentence and say that okay
uh we can give him 25 years uh 21 years
for the murder
you get him a manslaughter right
and
I don't know what type of stuff that
happens out of my presence between my
attorney and district attorney but I was
scared as [ __ ] I just received a life
sentence
uh I know I was bothering you sent this
to a life for the the rape and 25 or
whatever maybe 99 years for every own
robbery I don't know I was scared that
[ __ ] so I took the 21 year plea but I
never admitted to anything right
and the part of evidence was
that
the guy uh who we we talking about that
that
it was initially trying to involve me he
was found guilty of the murder already
so they were trying you for a crime they
already had convicted someone for
absolutely how is that possible it
happened
because that what they were trying to
say is that if two people are in a car
and you're both out committing crimes
right you're both responsible you're
both responsible there's something
called the felony murder Rule and the
felony murder rules that if you're in
the commission of a crime and somebody
dies so if you and I went and robbed the
bank
and I go in and start you know shooting
up the tellers and kill two tellers
you're responsible for the murder also
so the theory of Robert's prosecution
was that they were friends they were on
this crime spree together and that even
though he was convicted of the murder
um
you know
he was still responsible and guilty of
murder it's no different than the James
Daly case which I've talked about before
they convicted one guy Jack Piercy and
then they tried my client after that one
guy got sentenced to life one guy got
sentenced to death it's crazy that they
don't have to have any evidence
whatsoever that you even friends with
that guy right right it had his word
right isn't his word enough and and the
the piece of evidence another article
evidence that would help is a report
that uh that when he made a statement
like the money on my trial as I said
that I didn't have anything to do with
the murder you never knew me and
different things of that nature uh and
they withheld that and it would help
that
and that was so important to change the
outcome of my my trial because
they went they took me to trial on the
theory that we were friends and that I
knew him and that I had a connection to
him through the car but had I would have
had that piece of information the the
interjected my trial I would have never
probably got found guilty to that extent
and they also would have held various
different
um uh uh statements and evidence as it
relates to the witnesses that was very
inconsistent that was very favorable to
me
and that could have actually printed
back to the to the guy who was actually
uh uh uh convicted of the murder
uh
and attached to all those other spray of
crimes
um
yeah so it's this was a a lot of stuff
man that did withheld that that almost
made it impossible
um for me to unravel
and to uh to obtain my freedom and you
know I'd like to say that that's
uncommon too but it's not so in other
words when prosecutors are working on
one Theory full steam ahead right and
they then are met
with you might be wrong we might have
been wrong all along
the Instinct 99 times out of 100 is to
plow ahead and rationalize
why the true perpetrator in Robert's
case
why did he all of a sudden say Robert
had nothing to do with it oh well maybe
he is making this up because he feels
guilty that he implicated his friend who
really wasn't his friend I've in
Clementi aguirre's case which we've
talked about and your listeners know
about
the true killer confessed she confessed
over and over again to friends to
neighbors drunk not drunk to police in
denying him post-conviction relief now
this is a judge the judge chalked it up
a survivor's guilt
so in other words whether it's a
prosecutor's judges they'll make an
excuse to protect the prosecution
because it's all about winning or losing
let's talk about that what is that is
that human nature is it like do people
just want to confirm their initial
suspicions and they rationalize all
sorts of reasons why what they initially
thought was right and this new evidence
that shows that it's not right is wrong
like what what is it is that they don't
they don't just don't want to be
they don't want to lose I think it's a
fundamental flaw
that we have as human beings that I
share as a Taurus I especially share it
how dare you bring up astrology
but but I um
I'm stubborn but I think as I see this
time and time again and watching juries
deliberate because I do mock trials and
focus groups or speaking to people post
verdict but you can apply it
to politics to anything I think of one
fundamental flaw we have as mammals
is our inability to be flexible in our
reasoning and I think that once we make
a decision about something it's very
very difficult to get people to
reconsider I see that in really
intelligent people too and it makes me
sad it's maddening it's mad it drives me
crazy yeah because it's like you aren't
the the part of the problem I think with
police with prosecutors with the whole
legal system is that
it becomes a game and I don't mean a
game like it's a joke I mean a game like
you're trying to win yes and whenever
someone is involved in something where
they're trying to win
they do whatever the [ __ ] they can
people cheat they move golf balls right
they they do whatever the [ __ ] they can
don't look at Jamie
[Music]
you did hear golf ball well people cheat
man they they find ways to pretend that
they didn't do something when they did
it they find ways to justify the things
they did do they find ways to pass the
buck and put it on if if they can score
that W right and you see cops do it they
they plant evidence on someone they
think was probably guilty but they don't
have enough evidence on them they find
rationalizations and it's because
there's a game going on it's a win or
lose and it becomes a real problem and
not only that with a lot of cops
this quote is like you literally have to
arrest a certain amount of people right
which is insanity like what the [ __ ] do
they do if no one commits a crime what
do they do if no one speeds if you have
a quota where you have to arrest a
hundred people for speeding what the
[ __ ] do you do if everybody makes an
agreement we all get on Facebook and we
say hey
let everybody drive the [ __ ] speed
limit for the next 60 days and let's
crush the legal system because these
cops have to they have to make a certain
amount of pullovers they have to pull a
certain amount of people over and write
a certain amount of tickets they have
quotas if you don't meet those quotas
they get in trouble so what the [ __ ]
kind of game is that right I I would say
a lot a lot of that a lot of
just like we have structural racism
right and with when I say structural
racism I mean like institutional uh uh
things that set up to uh regulation
rules and policies like Redline right uh
and you just have like uh
flawlessness in a variety of different
systems they got people that work for
company they got a lot of flawless and
they don't really they don't really
understand that you're employed in the
system
that that that treat people unfair calls
people home and you can't even see it
and some people can be a part of a
system a part of a program or part of an
organization that
uh have that win mentality right that
women about all cause mentality and
they lose their empathy for people right
and and when people lose their empathy
when you know we didn't find those
things and a lot of people don't like uh
to hear this type of [ __ ] but when you
lose your empathy for people
you become technically a sociopath watch
the entire episode for free only on
Spotify